two military aircraft carrying the
bodies of 40 victims of the Malaysia
Airlines disaster arrived in the
Netherlands from Ukraine this afternoon
King willem-alexander led the
dignitaries on the tarmac at aint joven
airbase in all some 1,300 people were
there including many relatives of some
of the victims
at 4:00 p.m. they observed a minute of
silence
after leaving the airbase hearses
carried individual coffins to a military
facility in the north of the country
it's there that teams of experts will
attempt to identify the remains crowds
lined roads and bridges along the route
it was a chance for them to pay their
respects to the first of the victims to
return to the country the rest of the
Netherlands also came to a standstill
for one minute
flags flew at half-mast on a National
Day of Mourning
many are still trying to make sense of
the disaster crazy that so many people
died for no reason at all over half of
the passengers on board the downed plane
were Dutch one of them was Nina Curie
ani who worked at a fast-food restaurant
and ain't joven her boss says that she
loved to sing and to dance and that she
will be sorely missed that's her right
there and I always remember her this way
okay it's hard to imagine how she left
behind a husband a daughter and two
granddaughters her darlings a mom and
three clay the scratches fahadh the
clink in the the oak Apple's lanique was
on her way to Indonesia where she was
planning to visit her family now the
grim task of identifying the bodies can
begin the process could take months